la rencontre est brève mais bien réel à
8h30 vendredi un agriculteur de saint
marc la pila le temps de faire une
quinzaine de photos de l'animal femelles
ou mal an l'ignorent mais il s'agit bien
d'un canis lupus un loup gris les
empreintes relevées par l'office
français de la biodiversité le confirme
c'est un témoignage exceptionnel
effectivement plus de cent ans que la
présence du loup n'avait pas été signé
dans le département
c'est le sixième signalement en région
centre depuis depuis deux ans il n'y
avait que l'indre et loire qui n'avait
pas encore eu son signalement voilà ce
sont des loups erratique majoritairement
installés en meute dans les massifs
alpins le loup est aussi un voyageur
solitaire au printemps et à l'automne
certains individus se détache du groupe
pour trouver de nouveaux territoires on
appelle ça la dispersion pour l'instant
on n'a vraiment que cette observation de
vendredi matin et par la suite on verra
si d'autres signalements nous amène à
penser qu'il y aurait effectivement
peut-être une une installation ou en
tout cas le fait que l'animal reste un
peu plus dans le secteur mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas après
c'est des choses qui peuvent être
possibles ans a été le cas notamment en
normandie où dans les vosges on a là un
individu qui est parfois restée un peu
en train de les sédentariser sur un
secteur pour le moment on n'a pas
d'autres signalements donc voilà
l'animal a sans doute continuer son
chemin on verra ce que l'avenir nous
dira sur le sujet 80 cm au garrot 40 kg
pour les mâles 30 pour les femelles le
loup gris peut faire jusqu'à 100 km en
48 heures alors le loup de
cinq-mars-la-pile est peut-être déjà
très loin